Bien, si solo se enfocan en sus estudiantes más brillantes,
sabrán que crecerán las disparidades,
y verán mover esta burbuja ligeramente en la otra dirección,
pero aún, una mejora impresionante.
Una revisión importante en la educación polaca
ayudó drásticamente a reducir la variabilidad entre las escuelas,
mejorando muchas escuelas de menor desempeño
subiendo el desempeño en más de medio año escolar.
Y pueden ver otros países también.
Portugal pudo consolidar su sistema escolar fraccionado,
subir la calidad y mejorar la equidad,
y lo mismo Hungría.
Así que lo que ven es un gran cambio.
E incluso aquellos que se quejan y dicen que
la posición relativa de los países
en algo como PISA es solo un artefacto de la cultura,
de factores económicos, de temas sociales,
de homogenización de las sociedades, etc.,
esas personas tienen ahora que reconocer que la mejora de la educación es posible.
Polonia no ha cambiado su cultura.
No ha cambiado su economía. No ha cambiado
la composición de su población.
No ha despedido a sus profesores. Ha cambiado sus políticas y sus prácticas
educativas. Muy impresionante.
Y todo esto, por supuesto, nos lleva a la pregunta: ¿Qué podemos aprender
de estos países del cuadrante verde
que han logrado estos altos niveles de equidad,
altos niveles de desempeño y subido los resultados?
Y, por supuesto, la pregunta es, ¿puede, lo que funciona en un contexto,
ser un modelo en otro país?
Claro, no se puede copiar y pegar un sistema educativo a ciegas,
pero estas comparaciones han identificado una gama de factores
que comparten los sistemas de alto desempeño.
Todos concuerdan en que la educación es importante.
Todos dicen eso.
Pero la prueba de verdad es, ¿cómo se valora esta prioridad
contra otras prioridades?
¿Cómo pagan los países a sus profesores
en relación con otros trabajadores altamente calificados?
¿Te gustaría que tu hijo fuera profesor
en lugar de abogado?
¿Cómo hablan los medios de las escuelas y de los profesores?
Son preguntas críticas y lo que hemos aprendido
de PISA es que, en los sistemas de alto desempeño,
los líderes han convencido a los ciudadanos a tomar elecciones
que valoran la educación, su futuro,
más que el consumo hoy día.
¿Y saben qué es interesante? No lo creerán,
pero hay países en los que es más atractivo
ir a la escuela que al centro comercial.
Esas cosas existen de verdad.
Pero dar un valor alto a la educación
es solo una parte del cuadro.
La otra parte es creer que todos los niños
son capaces de triunfar.
Tienen algunos países donde los estudiantes
son segregados muy jóvenes.
Son divididos
reflejando la creencia de que solo algunos
pueden lograr altos estándares.
Pero generalmente eso conlleva grandes disparidades sociales.
Si van a Japón, en Asia, o Finlandia, en Europa,
padres y profesores en esos países
esperan que todo niño triunfe,
y lo pueden ver reflejado en el comportamiento de los estudiantes.
Cuando les preguntamos a los estudiantes qué importaba
para triunfar en matemáticas,
los estadounidenses típicamente nos decían,
todo es cuestión de talento;
si no nací genio en matemáticas, mejor estudio otra cosa.
9 de cada 10 estudiantes japoneses dijeron
que dependía de su propia inversión, de su propio esfuerzo,
y esto dice mucho del sistema que los rodea.
En el pasado, a diferentes estudiantes se les enseñaba de forma similar.
Los altos desempeños en PISA acogen la diversidad
con diferentes prácticas pedagógicas.
Se dan cuenta de que
los estudiantes normales tienen talentos extraordinarios
y personalizan las oportunidades de aprendizaje.
Los sistemas de alto desempeño también comparten
estándares claros y ambiciosos a lo largo de todo el espectro.
Todo estudiante conoce lo que importa.
Todo estudiante sabe lo que se requiere para triunfar.
Y en ninguna parte la calidad del sistema educativo
excede la de sus profesores.
Los sistemas de alto desempeño son muy cuidadosos
en cómo seleccionan y contratan a sus profesores
y cómo los entrenan.
Observan cómo mejorar el rendimiento de los profesores
en dificultades,
y cómo estructuran el pago de los profesores.
Proporcionan un ambiente en el que los profesores puedan trabajar juntos
para crear buenas prácticas.
Y les proporcionan caminos inteligentes para crecer
en sus carreras.
En un sistema escolar burocrático,
se deja a los profesores solos en las clases
con muchas indicaciones de lo que deberían enseñar.
En los sistemas de alto desempeño está bien claro qué es buen desempeño.
Se ponen estándares ambiciosos, pero después permiten que
los profesores averigüen
qué necesitan para enseñar a sus estudiantes hoy día.
En el pasado la educación se basaba en entregar conocimiento.
Ahora el reto es posibilitar la generación de conocimiento por parte del usuario.
Los países con altos desempeños han pasado
de formas administrativas de rendir cuentas y controlar
—cosas como, cómo comprobar si las personas hacen lo que se supone que deben hacer en educación—
a formas profesionales de organización del trabajo.
Le permiten a los profesores hacer innovaciones en pedagogía.
Les proporcionan la clase de desarrollo que necesitan
para desarrollar prácticas pedagógicas más poderosas.
La meta en el pasado era estandarización y cumplimiento.
Los sistemas de alto rendimiento han hecho profesores
y directores de escuela creativos.
En el pasado, la política se enfocaba en los resultados,
en proveer.
Los sistemas de alto rendimiento han ayudado a los profesores
y a los directores de escuelas a mirar fuera al nuevo profesor,
la nueva escuela.
Y el resultado más impresionante de los mejores sistemas educativos
es que logran altos desempeños a lo largo de todo el sistema.
Han visto que a Finlandia le fue muy bien en PISA,
pero lo que hace tan impresionante a Finlandia
es que solo hay un 5 % de variación en el desempeño
de los estudiantes entre las varias escuelas.
Todas las escuelas tienen éxito.
El éxito es sistémico.
¿Y como lo hacen?
Invierten los recursos donde pueden marcar la mayor diferencia.
Atraen a los mejores directores a las escuelas más difíciles,
y a los profesores más talentosos
a las aulas más desafiantes.
Por último, pero no menos importante, estos países alinean sus políticas
a todas las áreas de la política pública.
Mantienen la coherencia durante un período sostenido de tiempo
y se aseguran de que lo que hacen sea implementado consistentemente.
Ahora, saber lo que hacen los sistemas exitosos
no nos dice todavía cómo mejorar.
Eso también está claro, y aquí es donde están algunos límites
de las comparaciones internacionales de PISA.
Se necesitan otras formas de investigación,
y por eso PISA no se aventura
a decirles a los países qué deben hacer.
Pero su fortaleza se encuentra en decirles
qué están haciendo los demás.
Y el ejemplo de PISA muestra que los datos
pueden ser más poderosos que el control administrativo del subsidio financiero
a través del cual funcionan por lo general los sistemas educativos.
Algunos argumentan que
cambiar la administración educativa
es como mover las tumbas:
no se puede confiar en que las personas de adentro te ayuden con eso. (Risas)
Pero PISA ha mostrado lo posible en educación.
Le ha mostrado a los países que la mejora es posible.
Ha eliminado las excusas de los complacientes.
Y ha ayudado a los países a fijar objetivos significativos
en términos de objetivos medibles logrados por los líderes del mundo.
Si podemos ayudar a cada niño, a cada profesor, a cada escuela,
a cada director, a cada padre a ver que la mejora es posible,
que solo el cielo es el límite al mejoramiento de la educación,
estamos sentando las bases
para mejores políticas y mejores vidas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)